I know that there are a lot of common
questions that you're asked so what I
want to do is only yeah you're right I
don't know why anybody focuses on
anything other than just standing around
waiting for that damn thing to come out
there's only three of them found very 50
points and you know wipes out all of the
others it's like you know play the Super
Bowl as Super Bowl and you know you play
a regular game and then you know what
five minutes left someone in to call for
one
maybe onto something other golf clubs
involved in my name is Cody
I was wondering since you aren't very
interested in Quidditch what version of
fantasy or sci-fi sports ball do you
care for actually in the industry of
science fiction some fairly interesting
fake sports that that work better
there's of course vulnerable because the
subject of two movies one of them much
better than the others but the original
rollerball movie it was actually you
know pretty cool it's like roller derby
turned up to 11 and I think that would
have been been cool and as a kid I read
some of the earliest science fiction
books I read was the Tom Corbett space
space cadet series eight books so two
spun off a television show at the time
but I the television was a little before
my time but I read those those books
they were there were juveniles and as
they call them that they call them why a
about the you know Tom Corbett and his
Polaris crew and they were always
playing a game called mercury born now
mercury ball was basically soccer but
the ball had a vial of mercury inside it
and the mercury would shift and that
would make the ball turn you know you
can kick it but it wouldn't go straight
because the mercury would shift that it
would certainly turn to the left or
something like that so I always thought
mercury ball sounds like a lot of fun I
wonder if anyone has ever tried it but
hi my name is Russell and I was
wondering is there a character that
mirrors somebody that you have know in
real life that you may have kind of
patterned a character after as your
lawyer I would advise you not to answer
that yes certainly there are although
you know the main one that you always
draw on especially for a new point
character we are in their skin you're
hanging in courts it's yourself and all
of the characters have a little bit of
me and then put some of us are closer to
me than anyone else you know if you look
at the wild card books of course the
great powerful turtlecom is club areas
is practically autobiographical except
for the part where he developed
superpowers I wanted to develop
superpowers that I failed to do so but
tom is essentially mean well I would I
would actually say that you do have
superpowers you have the same
superpowers as Batman you have a dump
trucks full of money crime fighter he's
you know board meetings I'm asleep
during a day you know you can be one
thing like day and be another by night
because being a crime fighter like the
Batman is a nightly job you do it in the
dark and being a playboy is a drug after
their daughter again to night jobs and
though they don't even sleep all day
anyway
yeah cooking